[Music]
strap in you're about to blast off into
an entirely new Galaxy one that's full
of Epic Mega structures and Interstellar
travel this is a Type 3
civilization one of the most advanced
civilizations Humanity has ever dreamt
of normally we just talk about what a
Type 3 civilization might look like but
today you're going to visit it and
experience all it has to offer
is a world like this even
possible what would be the biggest
advancement this civilization would
have and why would extra planets be so
important okay you've made it to Galaxy
3812 a hypothetical Galaxy that houses a
type three
civilization but how did they get to
this Advanced Point well millions of
years ago this universe looked a lot
like ours it was known as a type zero
civilization then after generations of
research and hard work they figured out
how to utilize the entire power of Earth
all the energy produced by solar wind
and geothermal was at their disposal
Generations later they started traveling
to other planets and creating new
civilizations they're Now a type 2
civilization
and generations after that they've
become a Type 3
civilization what is a Type 3
civilization
exactly well you're about to experience
it firsthand but in short it means
Humanity can now control its entire
galaxy let's dive into more detail on
what that means for this
civilization one of the first things
you'll notice are the Dyson spheres that
surround the different stars in this
galaxy Galaxy these theoretical Mega
structures would be constructed of
incredibly strong Advanced Materials
that can cover a star and withstand its
extreme heat once this structure is
built it'll distribute power across the
solar system this will allow the
civilization to create and power things
bigger and better than ever before
Interstellar travel Planet colonization
and more that we'll get to a little
later on
you might see a couple of different
versions of these Dyson spheres as you
travel across the Galaxy there's the
classic Dyson Sphere a solid shell or
series of rings that fully wraps around
a star then there's the Dyson swarm a
group of satellites rotating around a
star collecting its energy and finally
there's the Dyson bubble this one is a
bunch of mirrors floating in space and
near the star the idea is that the
mirrors will redirect the star's energy
to where it's
needed okay we've stared at the sun long
enough now it's time to experience the
different ways you can travel around you
might fancy a hyper Advanced
spaceship SpaceX or NASA can't come
close to what a Type 3 civilization
offers you know climate change isn't
just affecting the Earth it's also
affecting your expenses yeah homeowner
insurance is getting more expensive than
ever thanks to Wild fires and floods in
fact as of October 10th there were 24
weather and climate disasters that have
cost the United States $1 billion in
2023 this has led top insurance
companies to raise premiums and to stop
issuing policies these extreme weather
scenarios may continue to make home
ownership more expensive and challenging
the only way to truly solve this issue
is to make sure we stop releasing
greenhouse gases into the atmosphere if
humans stop burning fossil fuels it'll
help change the course of climate change
and this extreme
weather hop into your futuristic
spaceship press a couple of buttons and
suddenly you're traveling to an entirely
different solar system how well you
could fly into a wormhole or a warp
drive that allows you to travel faster
than the speed of
light just make sure you set your
coordinates
correctly and if you want to take a
slower route without using any fuel you
can try traveling via solar Sails this
new spacecraft uses large mirrors to
propel itself using solar radiation
pressure from a star this will help you
travel longer distances without the need
to carry any fuel and it won't just be
about humans having new ways to travel
we'll also have things like launch Loops
to send materials around space these
would be long thin C cables that would
help materials travel through solar
systems they'd be constructed in a
straight line to help the materials
maintain their momentum as they traveled
through the tube this would allow
civilizations to easily transport
materials throughout the solar system
making space colonization faster than
ever speaking of which what would
colonizing space be like well let's take
our super Advanced spaceship and warp
over to the type 3 civilization 's most
populated
Planet as soon as you arrive you'll be
overwhelmed by an advanced and
futuristic space Colony but it wasn't
always like this millions of years ago
when this civilization was a type zero
this planet looked similar to what mars
or Venus might look like today the
environment was incredibly hostile to
human life it had no atmosphere and it
seemed imposs possible that billions of
people could live here one day but over
millions of years that's changed a large
part of this massive change was due to a
Type 3 civilization's power to terraform
planets that has given the civilization
the ability to modify key aspects of
planets in their solar systems from
adjusting the atmosphere to changing the
entire surface this could be done in
multiple ways a Type 3 civilization
might be able to Nuke a planet altering
its topography and releasing any gases
the planet might have they could also
release genetically engineered organisms
that can live on and alter the planet in
various ways you could release an
organism that might be able to suck up
or change any toxins in the
atmosphere regardless of the method used
after just a few decades a Type 3
civilization might have a hyper Advanced
planet that looks like this
and it wouldn't just be one or two
measle planets being colonized any
Planet they wanted to inhabit terraform
and populate they would this
civilization would have the technology
and power to do this at will even a
planet's orbit could be changed whenever
they wanted if the civilization really
likes a planet but they don't like it's
spot well they can move it to an area of
the solar system that would be easier to
sustain life
this would be done with things like
large scale thrusters and the ability to
alter
gravity but planets wouldn't be the only
places humans would live in a Type 3
civilization let's go check those out
okay remember the Dyson Sphere we looked
at earlier that's a mega structure and
there are a lot more of them throughout
the Galaxy one of them being the O'Neal
cylinder this habitat is a massive
rotating cylinder it's 6 1 12 km in
diameter and 26 km long this Mega
structure would house millions of people
and could feel exactly like Earth we
could control the temperature the
weather the day and night cycle whatever
we wanted another Mega structure we
could build for fun would be an Alderson
disc this would be like a massive disc
shaped version of Earth edge to edge
this DVD would be thousands of
kilometers long
but it wouldn't be as cushy as the
O'Neal cylinder that's because only the
inner parts of the ring would be
habitable for humans closer to the hole
it would be too hot and the edges would
be too cold but then again we're living
in a Type 3 civilization and we'd have
virtually unlimited power so Humanity
would probably figure out how to solve
these problems if we wanted to build
these Mega structures in our universe
Well we'd need to mine almost almost
every planet in our solar system but in
this type 3 civilization it's no biggie
since we could seamlessly travel to
multiple solar systems it would be easy
to mine a few solar systems that we
don't really care about now in addition
to all these incredible advancements
Humanity would be moving toward a type
four
civilization this means that they'd have
access to multiple universes and they'd
slowly be making their way toward
immortality want to see what happens in
the other types of
civilizations well that sounds like a
story for
another what
[Music]
if